what's happening forum okay so we're
gonna check the results from the
giveaway just so you know it's legit
nutrition sidekick journal total entries
1882 which is awesome
winners ready go winners to draw one
winner because we have one prize 650
potential users that can win let's draw
drawing the the winner is Thea Zen Tao
from Germany while congratulations you
are the winner of the giveaway I will be
contacting you via the email that you
provided your your Gmail thanks for
entering the contest everyone it was a
lot of fun we'll do some more contests
because I'm getting sent products all
the time
maybe I'll do a cash prize or one of
these things you guys gave my Twitter
follow or my Twitter following a huge
boost which was awesome talk to you soon
[Music]
all right how's it going everybody
welcome back to better ideas today we're
talking about focus how to focus why you
should focus and yeah that's basically
about it in a world where distraction is
becoming more and more of a problem
where social media is designed like slot
machines buzzing in your pocket
rewarding you with notifications and the
prospect of human connection it's really
hard to just focus on something boring
for a long period of time and I get more
and more questions in the comments
section being like how do I focus on
something I don't like focusing on or
something I need to focus on but it's
just boring I'm here to help you with
that and I've struggled with this my
whole life I thought I had ADHD for
pretty much my entire life and I might
still have ADHD but I think I fixed it
without drugs and and a lot of it came
down to some simple tips that I just had
to practice pretty religiously but it
pretty much solved my focused problems
didn't eliminate them completely I'm
still I still get distracted by video
games and social media just like
everyone else but I'm actually able to
stay focused for a really long period of
time and it's it saved my life
so I want to save your life too so we're
gonna jump right into it
I was editing this video and I realized
that the audio is all messed up for tip
number one so that's why it looks a
little different anyways tip number one
is to unstimulating so I don't know if
you've ever noticed this but whenever
you're binging memes on reddit or
playing apex your brain is really
stimulated and so when you try to hop
into doing something slower paced like
reading a book or writing an essay it's
really really hard to do that and that
has a lot to do with the fact that
you've conditioned your brain to expect
these feel-good chemicals like dopamine
and serotonin so when you're not getting
that from something slower paced like
reading a book or writing an essay is
really boring in comparison so what you
should do to fix that is take a break
from the stimulating activity that you
were just doing take a walk go to the
gym maybe go to the library and start
reading a book meditation is really good
maybe take a hot shower
but you've already in there for like
half an hour kind of a waste of time the
point being unstimulated your brain give
yourself a reset stop activating it with
so much stimulation that way when you
hop into doing something slower pace it
actually feels like you're getting a
natural amount of feel-good chemicals
for doing it this is also why I am such
a huge believer in doing your most
important work first thing in the
morning set a time where you can wake up
a little earlier than you normally wake
up to tackle that beast that you've been
avoiding you'll find that six to eight
hours or however many sleep however many
sleeps however however much sleep you
get in a night when you've had six to
eight hours to reset your brain you'll
find that boring activities are actually
you're actually able to focus on them a
lot easier this might sound like basic
advice but one of the most powerful
tools and your entire productivity
arsenal is to put your phone on do not
disturb mode that way when you enter a
flow state which we'll talk about in the
final tip you're not pulled out of that
flow state every two minutes because
somebody sent you a meme or like let's
see what do I get notifications about
yeah someone sent me an email somebody
on an Instagram group chat I don't know
posted something there's a discord thing
it's all meaningless stuff none of this
is nearly as important as doing my most
important video editing for Michael
early in the morning so stop letting
other people spend your time for you
this morning productivity time is for
you to do your most important work so
treat it with respect
all these other people who want your
attention can get it later on in the day
once you've done your duty okay tip
number two this is one of my personal
favorites and that is create a sacred
productivity playlist so most people
have a playlist that they listen to when
they're trying to be productive or do
homework or something like that usually
it's sort of a minimal electronic
background noise or some low fight chill
hop or some alpha waves or whatever when
you listen to a particular sound or if
you get in the habit of listening to a
particular kind of music while you're
being productive then your brain will
start to make the association that that
music is productivity music and whenever
you hear that music you're way more
likely to be productive when you listen
to it that being said it's kind of a
blessing and a curse you have to try
really hard not to goof off when you're
listening to your sacred productivity
playlist because once you goof off we'll
listen to that music your brain will
create that pathway and it'll be a lot
more easy to goof off again so if you
don't make it an option you can maintain
the sacredness of that playlist the
sanctity of that playlist create a
playlist that you only use for
productivity if you already have one but
you've goofed off while listening to
that music make another one make new
brain associations with that playlist
and only be productive while you're
listening to it
[Music]
tip number three is to use caffeine the
right way and yes I am the guy who made
a video about why you should quit
caffeine and I actually and actually
believe it or not I'm not a complete
hypocrite because I totally stand by
everything I said in that video if you
want to quit caffeine and because you're
finding you have too many peaks and
valleys in your energy levels throughout
the day then I think quitting caffeine
is a very constructive thing to do
because when you quit caffeine you get a
more steady reliable energy buzz
throughout the day the reason why I've
gotten back on caffeine is because I
actually need more peaks and valleys
throughout my day because I do super
focus work for a short amount of time
and then I'm done for the day or you
know I will have to run some errands and
then there'll be another period of time
where I need another caffeine boost and
for like two hours I'm super focused
again and then I'm done for the day I
have a really sporadic work schedule
like that
so caffeine suits my needs well however
it's not enough to just guzzle back
coffee without being methodical about it
so I have a couple tips on how to use
caffeine the right way or at least a
smarter way and my first tip is to not
have too much if you're exceeding 300
milligrams of caffeine a day you might
want to consider toning it back a little
bit because after that I find that
you're kind of you're too reliant on it
it's harder to wake up in the morning
you get like some crazy crashes and you
basically develop a pretty intense
chemical dependency on caffeine so if
you're under 300 milligrams check mark
number one check mark number two is to
space out your caffeine intelligently
don't have it all at once otherwise
you'll have a huge crash try to space it
out while not having an empty stomach
because according to caffeine and former
which I've been doing a lot of research
on it's a really cool website to learn
more about caffeine they recommend you
don't have caffeine on an empty stomach
if you want to avoid the crash and
lastly I find that combining caffeine
with l-theanine really helps mitigate
the crash helps mitigate the jitters the
anxiety and all of that kind of me
no temporary buzz you feel when you're
on caffeine it makes it longer lasting
and more steady so I would recommend
getting yourself some l-theanine make
sure you get the dosage correct
don't listen to some random youtuber
before you put random pills in your
mouth consult your doctor if you have
concerns look at the back of the bottle
all of that stuff I am NOT responsible
if you misuse l-theanine but I'm pretty
sure it's fairly harmless anyways before
we dive into the final tip let's just
have a quick word from today's video
sponsor of t shanley so according to
YouTube analytics 92% of my audience is
male especially between the ages of 19
and 35 so you're a bunch of young dudes
watching just like me so the guys over
at T's Handley sent me a box of this
skincare product and I don't know if you
can tell by the videos but I typically
don't have the greatest skin in the
world mostly because it's fairly
complicated for guys t shanley takes the
guesswork out of good skincare so all
the bottles are labeled super easily
it's super simple and once you make it a
daily habit to take good care of your
skin you won't have to worry about it
when you're older I know a lot of guys
who are in their 40s who always say like
I really wish I took care of my skin
when I was younger because now I look
like an old sock when you're a young
person you don't think you need to take
care of your skin because it looks
fairly good anyways but you're actually
just future proofing your skin so if you
take care of it now you're gonna be a
pretty good-looking forty five-year-old
55 year old heck I've seen 70 year olds
with better skin that I currently have
now it's because they probably use
something like T Shanley or just had
really good genetics I don't know for
the better ideas viewers T Shanley's
offering 20% off your first box so if
you're interested in getting a box of T
Shanley or just trying it out hit that
link in the description or use the
coupon code better ideas at checkout if
you don't like it cancel it but I would
recommend getting in the habit of taking
care of your skin you look sexier you
look younger for longer and it's just a
good idea in general
[Music]
so there's this thing called the
concentration hump I just named it now
it's not an official term or anything
like that maybe you've experienced this
in your life you finally are able to
grab yourself sit yourself down grab
yourself you're fine you're finally able
to sit down and start to write your
essay or file your taxes or read the
book you're at it for about five minutes
and then that sensation hits you where
you really want to quit like it's
becoming super boring it's becoming
unbearable you're starting to lose focus
so then you quit and you go do something
else as if five minutes was enough to do
any sort of meaningful work but that's
because you didn't push through the
concentration hump if you're able to
stick with an activity past the
20-minute mark then you'll enter the
flow state in which doing that activity
is way easier you've probably had a
crazy deadline that you like the fear of
God has put into you and you really just
have to sit down and do it regardless if
you enjoy it or not you've probably
found that once you sit down to do it
it's kind of hard at first but after
about 20 minutes of doing it you start
to get into a flow and then like things
are happening around you someone knocks
on your door and you're like don't like
don't it's almost like you're so into
doing that thing that nothing else in
the world matters you've entered the
11th dimension and all you have is that
thing in front of you that's the flow
state if you can make it past the
20-minute mark you can enter the flow
state so tip number four is be aware of
the flow state try to stick with it
uninterrupted for more than twenty
minutes and I guarantee you you'll enter
a flow state assuming that you have
notifications turned off which will just
completely ruin the whole thing and
you'll find that your most impactful
creative work will be able to be
accomplished with that hyper focus that
people seem to lack these days you'll be
a superpower so that's it if you like
this video hit that like button if you
like videos like these in general hit
that subscribe button join the Facebook
page we have a discord now you can hear
each other's voices talk with each other
if you want to eliminate teach handley
ads in my videos head over to my patreon
and start donating money so that I don't
have to have ads in the
my videos but if you're interested in TV
Hanley hit that link in the description
to get 20% off your first box your skin
will thank you and so your ladyfriend
[Music]